[Música]
me encanta que literalmente estamos
viendo la época en la que se está
viajando muchísimo más que ningún otro
tiempo cada vez más personas me platican
que están haciendo viajes increíbles por
todo méxico llenándose la cultura y la
riqueza del arte en nuestro precioso
país por otro lado están también las
personas que viajan lejísimos por todo
el mundo a nivel internacional
sinceramente esto me parece algo
maravilloso de este tiempo en el que
vivimos no obstante considero que hay
una tendencia particular a creer que
solamente haciendo un viaje sumamente
lejos pudiéramos llegar a tener un
encuentro con lo más íntimo de nuestra
persona con lo más íntimo de nuestro ser
creo más bien que hay otro viaje otro
destino al que no se le está haciendo
tanta publicidad y ese viaje en realidad
nos va a conectar con nosotros me
refiero el viaje hacia dentro de
nosotros hace dentro de nuestra mente
por medio de el autoconocimiento
algunos se preguntarán y que es el
autoconocimiento es poder responder
quién soy como soy que me gusta que me
disgusta que me hace estar feliz que me
hace entristecerme qué hago al respecto
cuando no me siento bien estoy
acercándome hacia mis metas me estoy
alejando de ellas que estoy haciendo por
los demás no estoy haciendo nada por mi
mundo no se trata de tener una respuesta
específica y super perfecta a cada una
de estas interrogantes más bien el
autoconocimiento y este hermoso viaje
hacia nuestro interior se debe de
practicar con la misma frecuencia con la
que cuidamos a nuestra higiene personal
todos los días todas las semanas todos
los meses desafortunadamente en mi
práctica como psicóloga he caído en la
cuenta de que existen muchas
dificultades para detenernos a hablar de
este tema parece ser que es un tema
y un poco intocable esto no es culpa de
nadie simplemente temas como pensar
sobre nosotros mismos viajar hace dentro
de nuestra mente ha tomado mayor
importancia en los últimos años a raíz
de que comenzó a tener mucho peso la
psicología positiva o la inteligencia
emocional
hace unos años no hace mucho tiempo
había un niño pequeñito se encontraba en
su primera infancia y sus padres ya le
habían enseñado cómo ir al baño por su
cuenta cuando él quisiera hacerlo
todas las noches pasa una situación muy
peculiar este niño veía monstruos a
través de alucinaciones visuales y temía
ser atacado y devorado por ellos esto
trae una consecuencia muy desagradable
para el niño él se hacía el baño todas
las noches y por ende sus padres siempre
lo regañaban continuamente por esto esto
se convirtió en un ciclo muy agobiante
para este pequeñito hasta que un día
decidió tomar las riendas del asunto y
estableció una tregua y más
específicamente un pacto amistad con
estos monstruos una noche les dijo hasta
que llegó el asunto les propongo un
pacto ahí les va como va a estar ustedes
no me van a atrapar no me van a tener en
sus garras no me van a hacer ningún tipo
de daño ya cambio de esto yo les voy a
ofrecer mi amistad por el resto de mi
vida
los monstruos confiaron en este pequeño
confiaron en él y dicho y hecho a partir
de esa noche nunca más volvieron a
cerrarlo ni le volvieron a dar miedo
incluso el niño literalmente tomó la
palabra sobre su propuesta y se hizo
amigo de ellos creció este niño y una en
sus abuelitas le dijo oye mi hijito
me gustaría regalarte un mono de peluche
qué quieres un osito un conejo un
canguro que te gustaría y el muy seguro
dijo a mí me encantaría un hombre lobo
porque no algo peculiar su gusto y la
abuelita pues me es imposible regalarte
esto no lo encuentro un mono de peluche
de esta manera y el niño con todo su
ingenio y su creatividad con sus propias
manos diseñó y construyó este hombre
lobo no sólo en su infancia sino también
en su adolescencia y su juventud este
niño demostró un cariño muy peculiar por
los monstruos las historias de fantasía
las historias llenas de magia
según cuando se convirtió en adulto ya
se había preparado en la elaboración de
guiones en cómo desarrollar un cuento
para un cine se imaginó siendo un gran
productor director y cineasta incluso se
metió muchísimo el tema del maquillaje
para darle vida de lleno a los monstruos
de los que se había hecho amigo desde
que estaba chiquito y esta persona a la
que estoy platicando a principios de
este año recibió el premio oscar por la
película la forma del agua y él también
se llevó el oscar como mejor director
estamos platicando de guillermo del toro
guillermo el toro desde una edad muy
pequeña comenzó a tomar una conciencia
de cómo era el que le gustaba que no le
gustaba cuáles eran sus áreas de
oportunidad cuáles eran sus sombras y lo
más hermoso de todo es que no sólo hizo
un autoconocimiento sino que abrazó
todos estos elementos hoy en día tienen
una autoestima muy sólida que le ha
ayudado a encaminarse a alcanzar
me estás creo firmemente en que todos
todos podemos llegar a alcanzar el sueño
que nos propongamos si al igual que
guillermo del toro hacemos un viaje
hacia adentro de nuestra persona por
medio de autoconocimiento hay tres
aspectos muy importantes que quisiera
resaltar de porqué trabajar en el
autoconocimiento número uno hoy en día
bastante se habla de la autoestima que
hay que querer nos hay que abrazarnos
pero como les dije en un principio me
doy cuenta de que existe la dificultad
para primero que nada auto conocernos
hay una definición muy hermosa de
autoestima que dice autoestima es la
persona que abraza admira y respeta al
conocimiento que tiene de sí mismo por
eso hoy les propongo primero que nada
auto conocernos para amar a nuestra
persona número 2 la depresión
dentro de poco se va a convertir en la
segunda causa de mortalidad a nivel
internacional esto solamente va a ser
superado por los problemas
cardiovasculares
tengo fe en que si a nivel social
educativo cultural se enfatizará más el
tema del autoconocimiento estos índices
de depresión pudieran verse modificados
y más aún las personas que ya padecen
depresión pudieran tener un tratamiento
mucho más fuerte más complementario por
ejemplo una persona con depresión que
trabaja el autoconocimiento se puede dar
cuenta que sentirse triste sin ánimos
con apatía es algo normal así como se
enferma el cuerpo también se enferma la
mente y esto le ayudaría a tener un
tratamiento muchísimo más eficaz en
tercer lugar en nuestra época actual
también se le da mucha importancia a las
relaciones interpersonales encontrar
pareja encontrar el amor pero no podemos
dar nada que no nos demos primero a
nosotros mismos por eso propongo primero
hacer un viaje hacia dentro de nosotros
conocernos muy bien
empatizar con nosotros mismos y entonces
ahora sí tratar de conocer
comprender entender y empatizar con las
otras personas
quizás algunos de ustedes se están
preguntando cómo pongo en práctica estos
elementos del autoconocimiento es un
proceso paulatino que lleva paciencia y
lleva esfuerzo y el día de hoy les
propongo una dieta emocional así como
hay dietas para bajar de peso para
mantener la talla
esto es una dieta emocional 100% para
nuestro cerebro en este caso esta dieta
estaría enfocada a aumentar nuestro
autoconocimiento 1 con los ingredientes
de esta dieta sería para empezar
eliminar el miedo que existe a estar en
silencio con nosotros a estar en soledad
es indispensable guardar momentos para
estar únicamente con nuestra propia
persona para escucharnos entender que
necesitamos cómo nos sentimos hacia
dónde queremos llegar en segundo lugar
otro ingrediente muy importante sería
eliminar el estigma que existe hacia ir
con un psicólogo un psiquiatra o un
coach
todos estos profesionales nos vamos a
enfocar precisamente a ayudar a hacer
este viaje hacia dentro de nosotros para
facilitar el proceso del
autoconocimiento otra herramienta de la
que podemos aprovechar que está muy al
alcance de nuestras manos es toda la
educación que existe hoy en día podemos
tomar cursos certificaciones meternos a
una universidad enfocarnos en este tema
podemos meternos en línea buscar libros
hay un sinfín de herramientas como para
aumentar
precisamente los elementos del
autoconocimiento
existe por ahí una frase de gandhi que
me parece 100% aplicable a este tema del
autoconocimiento el alguna vez dijo que
el cambio que quieres ver en el mundo el
día de hoy les propongo precisamente
empezar el cambio el tamaño que ustedes
deseen que sea por hacer un viaje hacia
dentro de nosotros si es importante
viajar a otros lugares no les voy a
decir que lo dejemos de hacer pero no
olvidemos la importancia y el peso tan
grande que tiene viajar así dentro de
nosotros estar en silencio escucharnos
apapachar a nuestra persona abrazar
nuestras luces y también nuestras
sombras porque gracias a ellas somos
quien somos hoy en día hagamos este
viaje constantemente por medio del
autoconocimiento
[Aplausos]
[Música]